All right, so this presentation is called healing begins with the gut and even if a cancer
patient comes to us many times, they're questioning why we're dealing with the gut when
they have brain cancer, they don't have colon cancer or stomach cancer, why do you have to
deal with the gut?
So I think I titled this presentation some simple things that you can do to help heal any disease.
This is important, so your gut is really your first line of defense against pathogens as
well as your first line of problems that you can start with.
So let's go back to that slide first here, the basis of disease.
So it starts with your stomach, it actually starts with your chewier food and digested
your food, but many pathogens that you deal with with all sorts of diseases and certainly
with cancer begin as foodborne pathogens and it has been said, Mike, made a comment
today about your pH and your pH is so important, he's talking about systemic pH, we want
to have, we don't want to have acidic tissue, cancer can grow in acidic tissue, cancer actually
produces acidity at that at that cancer site, but you do want acidity in your stomach.
So your stomach needs to be a very low pH, needs to be a very acidic environment.
When we lose that acidity in our stomach, we lose the ability to kill foodborne pathogens.
So acidity in our stomach has a purpose, which you are food, the talent is secreted by
our salivary gland, helps break down some of the carbohydrates, we swallow that food, the
hydrochloric acid in our stomach helps break down some of the carbohydrates and some of
the proteins before it goes into the small intestines.
Also the HCl in our stomach helps kill any pathogens and we're going to find who we're talking
about cancer a little bit later today, Hpilora is a big player with cancer.
So how do we kill Hpilora, well all of us are exposed to Hpilora maybe even every day.
So how do we kill it?
It's killed by the action of your stomach acid, primarily.
So I don't, I get an Hpilora infection that you do has to do with the level of your stomach
acid.
So we need to have a good secretion of stomach acid, maybe you could say one of the worst drugs
ever on the market are the acid blockers, that's arguable, but I would probably vote for
that in the top 10 for sure.
Acid blockers decrease the stomach acid secretion, thereby oh my gosh, my tummy doesn't hurt
anymore.
I get this acid reflux, so that must mean that I have too much acid we think.
So we're going to take tums and we're going to take role aids or we're going to go to prilosec
or something like that, that's going to block the stomach acid production and what does that
do?
It makes my tummy feel better, but it causes way more problems.
So usually when I have acid reflux in my stomach hurts after I eat, I burp it up some acid.
That's really a sign of hypochloridria, a too little stomach acid production.
So that the food is sitting in the stomach, there's not enough acid to break it down, there's
not the signaling molecules that tell it to be released into the small intestine because
it isn't being digested, because I have a decreased HCl production.
So then what little HCl is there gets gurgled back up into the esophagus and then I get this
heartburn formation.
Well tums take care of it but it's actually making the problem worse.
Also I increased the pH of my stomach so I'm not digesting my food, so I'm sending food
into the small intestine only partially digested and that causes all sorts of problems.
I'm not killing the pathogens that come along with the food so now I'm introducing a whole
bunch of pathogens into the small intestine that never should have been introduced into the
small intestine in no way enzyme system that's taking place in my small intestine is even
more taxed.
Not a good thing, if you have stomach issues you probably have hypochloridria.
Matter of fact you could argue that maybe everybody has hypochloridria, why is that?
How could everybody have this thing?
Is this a disease?
Why does everybody have it?
It's a new thing.
Well the problem is we have an American diet that has all sorts of additives, calories,
membranes, all these different things that block stomach acid production.
Matter of fact if you go back on our website I think I have several videos that talk about
the whole ins and outs of how stomach acid is produced in your stomach and what blocks
it.
And it's big part of it is our American diet with all the different things that we have
in it that affects that.